in the inaugural season of Netflix's The
Witcher the law of surprises the hinge
upon which the entire plot twists but
for those coming to the series having no
familiarity with the property it may
seem a bit confusing what does the law
of surprise mean to Geralt in its world
the concept has taken many forms across
a lot of cultures folklore but it
basically boils down to this in exchange
for an unpayable debt usually saving
someone's life
the person who invokes the law is
demanding the benefits of the targets
unexpected luck this can be anything but
the trick is that the item is bestowed
by luck and fate and is unknown to the
person giving the item away until they
return home safely many parables involve
the trope of a nobleman travelling and
having their life saved by someone of
lower birth rather than accept the
immediacy of gold or other form of
material wealth the peasant will invoke
the law of surprise which leads to the
nobleman having to give up something far
more precious when the nobleman grows
selfish and attempts to thwart this
invocation of fate by either trying to
pay the peasant off or attempting to
kill them terrible things befall them
tales using this trope are meant to
highlight the virtues of selflessness
and humility good people in King's honor
their bargains even when the cost is
exceedingly high and the universe should
punish those who do not
here's how the law of surprise comes
into play in the first season of The
Witcher many years before the events of
the series Lord
Ian Hummel died at the realm saves the
king from death with extreme humility
Archean and [ __ ] needs no material
benefit for doing so but upon the Kings
continued pressure chooses the law of
surprise as its repayment never once
imagining it would mean coal Anthes
unborn child having been cursed to look
like a hedgehog from a young age he did
his best to stave off the fate the law
of surprise demanded until his curse
lifted hearing the twelfth peal of a
bell in the course of his life fades of
course intervenes and her cheon meets
princess pavada seemingly by chance and
they fall in love
their secret betrothal is what drives
him to interrupt the feast of sintra
demanding what is his by ancient rite
syndra then i come to kill you what is
rightfully mine
perfecta by the law of surprise queen
clan 'they gets mad there's that big
fight and gerald steps in directly to
save Yuans life twice in succession when
calamity finally relents her cheon
insists just as the king had done years
before to repay Geralt for his
intervention Geralt believing all this
to be traditionalist nonsense chooses
the law of surprise / literally everyone
else's interruption that may be garel
buddy you should think it through
alas he does not and the cheeky
revelation of pavetta vomiting
immediately afterward reveals her
pregnancy ciri is on the way and Geralt
refuses to recognize what he has wrought
for himself he mocks the concept of
destiny openly to his friend mouse X
warnings and leaves to his continued and
countless future troubles it's only when
he accepts his responsibility under the
law of surprise that he is put at ease
Geralt is sympathetic he is a man of
forced circumstances living a life he
had no choice in and basically waiting
to die though he strives to at least be
effective in his profession this until
of hope for something better through
yennefer is lost precisely because of
the selfishness to which he employed the
law of surprise thinking he cheats
someone out of a child he could never
bear himself with no consequences and
when it got tough abandoning ciri to a
much uglier fate than necessary both
gerelds and kill anthe thought destiny
was hogwash tried to abuse others belief
in it for their own ends and ended up
severely punished for it
gone outrun destiny just because you had
terrified
of it it's coming Geralt not believing
won't change that the punishment is one
engenders belief in fate but too late
for clampy and almost so forget serious
consequential both because of the potent
magical bloodline she belongs to as well
as her unknown attachment to Geralt
through what amounts to his own selfish
stupidity it's much more than a simple
bit of moral instruction to the world of
The Witcher it's magic making itself
known in its world and the mortals
within its are merely shifting among its
tides check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Applause]
[Music]